[Music]
just as our economy was shaking off the
pandemic shock
russia's war of aggression against
ukraine
has brought extraordinary
economic uncertainty back to europe
the war has triggered renewed upward
pressures on commodity prices
has aggravated supply disruptions and
dampened consumer and business
confidence
all these factors exacerbate
pre-existing headwinds
to economic expansion
the search in energy and food prices is
reducing households purchasing power
but the post-pandemic economic reopening
especially in the services sector
a strong labor market and the lower
accumulation of savings are supporting
private consumption
war induced supply chains disruptions
are adding
to the disturbances in global trade
due to the drastic covet 19 containment
measures
being applied in parts of china
in this context
euro-area inflation in april surged to
its highest rate since the introduction
of the single currency
it is projected to remain high this year
before falling in 2023
while investment growth is said to be
constrained by rising production costs
tightening financial conditions
and heightened uncertainty
the recovery and resilience facility
and front-loaded energy-saving
investment will be supportive factors
the labor market
enter this new crisis on a strong
footing with record low unemployment
levels
and unemployment is expected to further
improve this year and next
government deficits
are expected to continue declining as
covet 19 support measures are completely
phased out
and this is said to outweigh
the additional costs of mitigating the
impact of high energy prices
and to support people fleeing ukraine
this forecast is of course subject to
considerable uncertainty
given the exceptionally tense
geopolitical situation
russia's unprovoked invasion of ukraine
poses enormous challenges for our
economies
and it's more important than ever that
we remain united
and stand ready to adapt
our economic policies
to the rapidly evolving circumstances
you